can a game company make a sweet-ass
trailer for a game and have the game
live up to the hype that's the real
question right there Dead Island are so
some months ago we all remember seeing
the trailer for Dead Island I mean I
made a video about the trailer for Dead
Island it was a sweet-ass trailer I mean
the little girls running from the
zombies half the trailers plane forward
the other half splaying backwards
playing that song that sounds like the
song from lost that plays when people
die it was great it was awesome and so I
got the game and I played the game I'm
gonna let you know right now the game
does not live up to the hype it doesn't
first of all it's a first-person game
that has all like melee weapons and I
heard that going in and I was like
that's kind of interesting let's see if
they can implement that into a zombie
game and make it work still waiting for
a game to make it work because this one
did not do that I mean at first the game
is slow it's really light on story I
mean it's heavy on missions you go and
do missions and whatnot but the story's
just not there yeah you go to bed one
night wake up the zombies are loose
that's it after that you get sticks and
boards and you go fight them off to do
missions for people it's kind of funny
my friends saw me playing the game and
then like a couple days later he saw me
again and he was like dude are you using
a stick you were using the same stick
the last time I saw you I mean when I'm
fighting zombies in a game and I get a
really sweet weapon you know as far as
the game goes I shouldn't be like oh
dude score awesome can't even believe I
got that that is badass
how hyped should I be that I just got a
hammer I mean seriously it's supposed to
be realistic on a resort there's not
going to be a lot of firearms I get that
into its credit it is realistic as far
as zombie games go you have your melee
weapons you try to fight them off you
die like you would in a zombie outbreak
or you run from them and don't even
fight him at all like you would in a
zombie outbreak when you have like a 2x4
to fight them off in which case you're
like alright I lived so maybe I'm
supposed to do that but that's boring
what kind of zombie game has you not
fight zombies and just run from them
realistic yes fun no I mean when it does
things right it doesn't right there are
very few things more gratifying than
having a zombie just ravenously run at
you and you have your machete and you
swing at that right time and take his
head clean off he doesn't even touch you
that's awesome that being said that's
usually not how it goes
usually swing too soon in which he gets
you or you don't swing fast enough in
which he hits you the problem is it's
the first person game that deals with
melee weapons like Dead Rising was a
third person game so you can use
sledgehammers and machetes and swords
and things like that because you can see
how far away your character was from the
zombie first-person game there's no
depth of field so
you swing you're like I think that's
Farah it's not he got me and that's just
if it's one-on-one later on in the game
all the zombies start running after you
and they all run after you in groups of
five you have this move where you can
kick them in the head that keeps one
away the other four hit you my favorite
thing is when they start gang banging
you and you just die and you're dead
before your lives even gonzo oh really
my life bar still going down is already
game over at a point when the zombie
started running after you in mobs like
left 4 dead 2 and I realized left 4 dead
2 has the worst case scenario being you
have your handgun has unlimited ammo and
Dead Islands best-case scenario being
you have a machete I knew there was a
bit of a balance problem I mean later on
you do get some guns but there's a
problem with that - when I found guns I
loaded up on guns I was like sweet I'm
done done I'm awesome then I ran out of
ammo and I had nothing I had like two
hammers yeah you can modify weapons and
whatnot that's all cool and dandy but
dead rising - modded weapons and that
did it better it also was third-person
so you could see if your weapon was
gonna hit the guy or not
I think realism in this game was out the
window the moment I said yes to a girl
whose mission was for me to get her
teddy bear yeah I'm gonna face off
against fifty ravenous zombies out there
so she can get her teddy bear back
that's not realistic I tell her to [ __ ]
off and you realize that dying becomes
part of the strategy usually in the game
when I have to get from point A to point
B and I die like here and it starts me
out there and I'm like dude I missed
that whole section in between I'll go
back and try to do it this game I was
like nope I'm taking it I'm going just
whatever I missed it at that point you
know the game had a misstep or two
somewhere along the line dying should
not be okay let alone be a part of the
strategy to beat a game it's a big red
flag in a game almost as big as having
your main motivation for beat in the
game being to beat it so you can trade
it in soon so the trade-in value doesn't
go down too much and that ain't good
it's not good and the characters they're
really light on story and the argument
could be that you're supposed to put
yourself in the first person of these
characters so it's supposed to be you
but unless the backstories like I did
youtube videos then this happened
now we're here it's not me it's some
other guy that has his own backstory or
girl once you get the characters a
backstory it's not you anymore in the
end I see the potential of Dead Island
if they make a sequel it could be really
good this one had a hundred missteps and
it's not even a fun game to play it's
just a grind you just want to do it to
get through it if I didn't have to do
this video I wouldn't have played it but
character stories were light the game
story was light until later on the game
starts getting a little better but still
it wasn't the vibe of the trailer that
came out some months ago I mean if
you're subscribed to me you
like movies and if you like movies
you've seen this a hundred times over no
movie that has a really sweet trailer
than the movie comes out and it's just
not good
Dead Island is that scenario for games
the games unbalanced as hell you're
gonna die a hundred times you're going
to get frustrated and I'm pretty sure
guys just spawn behind you I would walk
around I'm like there's nothing behind
me I cleared this entire path it's a
hallway then all of a sudden something's
hit me from behind I turn around there's
a zombie there I know he spawned I don't
really have a rating system for games I
would say skip the game entirely but if
you really need to play it and if you
saw the trailer you probably do I'll say
rental I do the Netflix thing you know
where you send off and they have to like
send you a disk cause you pay your
monthly fee have them send you dead
island so your favorite zombie game I
got to ask you what is it comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more